I mean that would cut off a finger for
her there are there are those women out
there cut my [ __ ] finger off I want
to show my dedication to her down
well there are women that you give a
pinkie
now you'd give the first knock first no
no not the whole pinkie right no I'll do
hoping because I don't really need I'll
do that maybe that's a lot that's a lot
of that what for hurting for her I'll do
the alternate take get her off get her
off she's married for the kids she's a
married woman with a kid those are small
details all right here's why you can't
use you can't take this finger to you my
hands a turtle we need that for shooting
they don't ninja turtles do it
we just went shooting you know that you
don't need your pinkie you need that you
need your ring finger your middle finger
your index finger and your thumb you
gotta have the Robocop it up because
when I'm doing my tactical shooting I
need I don't need my paint [ __ ] hit my
video me being [ __ ] John thick so
funny think was the greatest I was
laughing so hard that watch this I was a
video foul that a myth
Charice them by hit hit hit hit hit [ __ ]
on the ground
pow pow yeah they have that little kick
done detection I kid it's a small person
let's get it let's get it correct that
boom look at that dude now that's a very
expensive
that's an ar-15 the one they used in
John wick I guess that's what they tell
me
daddy's trying to shoot them they did
some shooting at a place called Tarrant
tactical and Boyd ten doesn't mess
around
no he's how about I guess he was the
best in the world for nine years ten
years he said yeah like he they did but
three guns shooting with his pistol
tactical shotgun ar-15
correct me if I'm wrong once you start
doing that me Rogan and you were out
there and and you get kind of addicted
to the speed of it I was trying to
[ __ ] hit those chichi chichi I was
inpatient oh and daddy just wants to
blast away like I'm Isis if you don't
like the
like going through the reload the draw
all that stuff is very boring today you
just want to get it give me the yeah you
know when you left I worked the assault
rifle and a little um Italian I know
that's what I was looking for the guys
want her to buy for her daddy's gonna
buy that for that daddy's accurate
burglars burglar from me I got my
tactical shotgun and I'm very me my
daddy's gonna light him up like it's
zero dark thirty I got my custom
outfitted Glock yeah but he showed us
that that assault rifle he's gonna build
for us hmm
finding the kid assault rifle yeah one
for the fighter one for the kids right
well it's very importantly sorry for
them already I want to be [ __ ] ready
you know that was fun I'm addicted
there's a lot that goes on there's a lot
that goes on to shooting there's a lot
that goes on he's saying most people
when they go to holster the gun is when
you shoot you that's what do you we
share who works there let's go Barris it
yes the bullet the bullet bunnies are
heavy around them yeah they're heavy
thumpers yeah and I call them heavy some
pretty good shoes I was trying to with
Alicia she was pulling drawing and I was
trying to draw and shot that's what they
do
she was beating me by a full sec I was
watching it was driving I kept looking
over go for [ __ ] second then they
have guns where you can use lasers now
what I do Danny me and Taryn would laugh
at you know this right behind your back
yeah cuz I was trying to do it second
the second day my second time shooting
now shoot when my eyes open and I was
actually pretty damn well I'll go back
no decimals now daddy goes look pence I
think who's that crossfitter played or
no that's broke pants I think yep I'm
very happy with the way she shoot I'm
not mad at it oh [ __ ] she's a shoe shoe
shoe shape this is Brooke ence Brooke
pence Brooke she's like a fan
crossfitter the other name wrong but
what is it pen sense there's no pee oh
damn she's super buff oh yeah sure god
she's odd she's in take it to shred Vale
yeah take the shred bill um well you
want it you want to you want to stay
hard and
want your guns ready yeah tactical
shotgun is next I want to do that I'd
like to shot old what'd he say we're
going back this week yeah and then he's
getting one of those those live her
body's ridiculous yeah one of those live
way shredded one of those live dummies
that let she look like person and when
he shoot it shows the blood splatter
memory show us the video he's like this
why won't you guys just like $5,000 a
doll oh yeah now it's $2,000 mm so it's
an actual show um it's on Amy where they
cut into they like build old-school
weapons and they cut into the the the
doll yeah kind of yeah it's got blood
it's got fortune my god it's as close as
you can get to a human body I found that
to be that that disturbing you and I
both are see when you're shooting guns
in that environment and then you see
video of a dummy that looks like a human
body with blood in it gets shot and then
I reminded you of that guy who got his
face chewed off by the grizzly bear both
of our backs got really tight yeah my
back gets tight I whenever I'm at a
shooting range Egyptian I can assure
there you go that's it I get super
maggot action up real tight my back
daddy's back that tight yeah daddy's
back I don't like violence like that
when you see what what those bullets can
actually well he goes this what it looks
like he took a nine-millimeter shot in
the head and it just shows all the blood
it was at some kind of a special how
about when Jaime and rogue I go can you
imagine shooting actual human wrong
goose sure can yeah sure can although
yep what well he goes that burger like
came in your house at one time you would
have shot him in the face right
fair point I was talking to a a seal
hood seal team DEVGRU guys do tell you
to wear socks no he'd been no I'm cool
he'd been um he'd done a lot of faction
you know he's a seeing some stuff he see
I soul snatcher and he and I said I said
to him I said when you get when you
shoot somebody a lot of times like with
a like an ar-15 is gonna do some serious
damage but like a pistol and stuff
people it's not like you should pop up
and he just Falls sometimes you've gone
they keep going to pull they're gonna
shoot you too so you got to be you got
to be shooting for center mass I double
tap
pop pop center mass
hey oh I do uh you walking dead only
I've had shots on only headshots
by the way you were shooting dicks and
heads he was on writers Brendan was
shooting Dixon heads and Taran was like
you're hitting you're hitting him in the
dick and now you're hit him in the head
can you go center-mass please
and Brendan was like nope you aim high
game hi yeah I'm um I'm gonna be a race
now I'm gonna beat ya bro I'm gonna well
I watched a movie and the guy was
holding the gun and I was like okay dude
write your own the gun wrong okay yeah
like I was watching taken last night
just the end of see how you held gun yes
like it's your thumb bro were your thumb
so you need a lot of shoot guns since I
was a little kid really yeah
my dad taught me oh [ __ ] well you're
Korean they're [ __ ] hardcore and he
was military as a Marine so he was a gun
collector - he's like Korean Marines are
no joke your dad's no joke a buddies are
riot yeah so you dad taught you how to
shoot how to take apart put together
clean shoot Wow make you recite stuff
like this is my gun this is only my gun
no great without this guy and I am out
stuff [ __ ] don't
don't [ __ ] you're not gonna push
cheering he's not gonna fall over cuz
he's not a pushover I'm not a pushover
understand me I'm gonna challenge chin
telling his audience yeah we got cat it
comes at me your [ __ ] through Vietnam
the only country it has never actually
ever been caught ever been conquered let
me know what I mean it was colonized for
a short time there like the Afghani
they're like yeah we'll let you say stay
here for a second but by the way never
forget we're Fiat nummy so get the [ __ ]
out of here
mm-hmm and you're gonna fight him and
they'll [ __ ] build tunnels
underground yeah yeah they've got a
[ __ ] hands for ice yeah and you know
what my for this guy who's a marine in
Vietnam finger in life in Vietnam said
he was at marine he had frag all over
here shrapnel all of his legs face
Geoffrey amazing guy who took us through
Afghanistan a fake Recon Marine he said
that Vietcong they were all headshots
man they just you they were such good
shots head shots don't [ __ ] with the
Koreans of the Vietnamese no reason to
though either you know reason to me I
don't take a reason to have your forest
yeah George uncle a friend of mine I
kind of already enjoy your jungle and
bugs a friend of ours who's a who's done
some drug dealing you and I know he said
he said to me he goes there was some
guys and I said well those guys and he
said I just guys you know I said hmm
they look interesting he is he goes
whenever you see an Asian guy
whenever you see a Vietnamese guy with
traps he's probably a criminal that's
very accurate very accurate right yeah
like a full body and I was like oh yeah
guys have [ __ ] traps because yeah
usually that's a criminal right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]